as javascript developers we often make  prolific use of console.log to get our  code working everybody's doing it but  that's not exactly something we like to  brag about  more cultured back-end developers who  print to the standard output might laugh  at you for using a silly debugging toy  like console log luckily there are two  ways to avoid console log shaming in  eslint you can use the no console.log  rule to warn you before this pointless  code ends up embarrassing you in  production option two is to replace  console logs with log points in vs code  right click next to a line number choose  log point add your message and use  braces to add expressions or variables  from your code now run it in a debugger  and you get all the benefits of  console.log without the code